[Music]
this morning a special edition of the
dish from the super bowl city of Atlanta
in 2017 eater named B's cracklin
barbecue as Atlanta's restaurant of the
year saying it's a must visit for the
city's barbecue lovers Dana Jacobson had
a chance to talk with owner Brian Furman
a South Carolina native whose shaking up
the barbecue scene in the South's
biggest city Dana yabbies cracklin
barbecue guys is about a 20-minute drive
from where I am here in downtown Atlanta
but it has become a destination for
barbecue fans from across the globe
when Brian Furman puts together his
sampler plate he knows that people may
come in for the meat but says it's the
sides that complete the dish all right
that looks good not gonna lie this is
all for me right Brian yes ma'am
B's cracklin barbecue Furman's
restaurant has been getting a lot of
buzz since opening in 2014 is this
Atlanta barbecue my barbecue I feel like
I got my own style his style is homemade
like the three cheese mac and cheese
baked beans with brisket scraps and fat
and cracklin hoecakes
and this is your special sauce yes
that's the peach mustard and homegrown
pork that he smokes in the back of the
restaurant bacon meat and hammy and
that's why the sandwich and the port
different Furman is no stranger to fire
before mastering the art of smoking meat
he worked as a welder for the company
JCB as for his current title he refrains
from the traditional label bestowed on
the kings of barbecue
I don't even label myself a pitmaster
you don't know like my grandma my
granddad my dad you never label
themselves a pitmaster okay my grandma
never label itself a chef
his grandmother also taught firm in a
thing or two about livestock
we're always eating things that farm on
the backyard and a garden I'm raising on
Felix raising on chickens so I grew up
basically made from scratch everything
food has always been kind of like my
thing but I just didn't look at it as a
business that changed when Furman who
suffers from migraines needed a spinal
tap that put him out of work for months
I got back to work I told my friend if I
walk through these doors 2015 you'd be
right to slap me he just laughed and I
was like I'm serious and June when I
signed a lease and I told her I quit my
job
open beans when you told your dad you
wanted to do barbecue he he asked you a
question that really helped shape some
of what you do uh-huh what was the
question what was gonna make me
different than everybody else
he found his answer back on the farm
heritage pigs which he rears from the
farm in Statesboro Georgia
to the table the heritage breed is a old
lining of pigs if you put these pigs in
the command system they won't they won't
live they won't work they won't walk on
concrete they stress they won't eat so
they had to live on dirt and you saw
that this was the best-tasting meat came
from these pigs yeah and then what was
the thought burden barbecue it's kind of
like cheating Fuhrman open bees cracklin
in Savannah before expanding to Atlanta
it's a family affair
his wife Nikki left her career as a
property manager and their two teenage
sons worked for him after school
but Fuhrman doesn't see bees as a
mom-and-pop shop his goal has always
been to open a new restaurant every year
the latest is in the renovated home of
the NBA's Atlanta Hawks State Farm arena
people go to business school for years
to try to figure it out and restaurants
still fail I'm laughing because to be
honest with you like business to me is
common sense either you're born with it
or you're born without it Fuhrman
credits his success to a keen instinct
years of hard work and 2013 my horoscope
was like your empire were flourished for
the next 19 years doesn't my horoscope
said and I'm like Empire I'm just maybe
with the Stars being aligned guys I got
enough barbecue for all of us but you're
not here to eat it with me so it does
not travel well I did however get
something that will of course a cocktail
glass with a Super Bowl theme and then
Michelle I know who you're rooting for
on Sunday because you're Saints aren't
in there so I got you a hat for your new
favorite team the Patriot it's not like
I haven't worn that hat before my super
cities challenge so you know thank you
so much I so appreciate that I'm gonna
have to deal with the bitterness back
here I hope Brian Foreman brings up
brings one of these next restaurant in
New York cuz that looks so good